it's so hard for all of us to do
anything
fun during this quarantine my family and
i we had this idea which is we'd take a
road trip and literally just stay in our
car as much as possible and i know that
you did something kind of like that you
and your husband got in an rv
is that right yeah we had the same
thought
and and that was a way that we i mean i
we actually traveled you mentioned
yearly departed we were traveling from
new york to la to shoot yearly departed
and wanted to figure out how to do that
as safely as possible and to arrive
in in one piece but yes we have the same
thought
you took a picture that you also posted
and i think this is your husband in the
rv
chilling out looks like uh it looks like
he's having his breakfast
and then for some reason there's a
cardboard cut out of
you uh behind him in the rv
what's what's all that about yeah so we
we wrapped dearly departed um some of
our producing partners on the project a
company called done and dusted they
produced the emmys and if you remember
at the emmys the audience was filled
with cardboard cutouts so my wrap gift
was my cardboard cutout which was
swiftly defaced with all kinds of you
know
uh pee pee and and other things that i
will um
leave for the imagination and uh and so
we
you know what what does one do with a
cardboard cutout
of yourself it's like i can't throw it
out that feels wrong and so we
we brought her with us and um and she
haunted us uh in the rv in our dreams
and now she's still here in my apartment
yeah
it's weird i mean first of all you ask
what does one do with a cardboard cutout
of
yourself i know the answer to that
question
um i've been having them made for years
and i just love i just love hugging
myself
um i've had a cardboard cut out of
myself and i've thoroughly enjoyed it
in every possible way because i'm a
narcissist but you guys look like you're
having fun with it because you've been
taking these pictures i don't know if
this is you or your husband
around the house but i i really love the
ones where like this is you i guess
leaning in with your dog yes or a dog
unless he's a cardboard cutout too
improper
ppe usage i have to point out
yes that's nice that's winston he's
confused you've got one
here that uh of just you it looks like
uh just with
uh bottles of alcohol just chilling
yeah and then my favorite though i like
any peeking photo
this to me that's the best use of a
cardboard cutout there's nothing
better than it in the background just
peeking out
to me i don't know to me that's the
finest use of any cardboard cutout it's
just peering out a little bit
i really screwed up not placing her back
here for this
for this interview yeah i think you know
we've reached the point in
in lockdown life where we've been
together for many many months
we we're getting our kicks from from
hiding the cardboard cut out
of me around the house and trying to
scare it it works
it's frightening you know what you
should do is just have it looking out
the window
because people burglars will always
think you're at home
so that's not a bad idea that's an
excellent idea it's also a great way to
let
everyone know where i live yeah i i did
as i was saying it i remembered oh right
uh she's really famous that's a bad
famous but idea this no no no here wait
nowhere
trust me trust me you've you've achieved
a certain level of fame where
where it's not a deterrent to have a
cardboard cut out of you
peering out of your new york apartment
right yeah so
yeah i think we are like i mean what do
you i'm
i can't ask you because you you love
your cardboard cutouts i think
i think she's she's overstayed her
welcome but i i have i'm
struggling with the idea of like cutting
her into small pieces
and putting her in a garbage bag yeah
that that
sounds uh creepy and wrong yeah and i
would say
send her to me but that's again the
wrong message
my wife would uh
every idea i have is worse than the
previous idea
so let's just pretend i haven't said
anything